okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today
i'm gonna be talking about a common
complaint that i get on my channel
common
every time i ask for donations i'm
raising money for something
this is the comment
no disrespect but ain't your people's
rich
don't you average parents
why don't you just ask your parents
okay
let's let's talk about that
being a hundred percent
honest okay my parents have helped me
out with certain like donations or
certain things i'm trying to buy like
yeah
my parents definitely support me um
it's not like i just have access to
their money or anything but if i have
something like that i'm trying to buy
for the channel at times they will
donate but the thing is my parents are
business people like they want to see
that i have a viable business model so
basically
i have six more months in london to show
that this is a viable business model and
that people want this content enough for
me to keep doing it
if in six months i'm not making any
profit i'm not generating any revenue or
it's not improving then
i likely won't keep doing this because
why would i do something that's not
making any money because if i'm not
making money at it
that's indicating
that the demand just isn't there for
this type of content
um
and i think if people knew how much like
you actually take home in this stuff
it's not much
like i've put a lot of my own money and
my parents money into this like building
this brand
which is fine right like when you're
building something that's totally fine
but
the reason i ask for money and donations
is to prove that like
the the demand is there one and two
uh my parents aren't just gonna fund
every single
piece of the way if there's no demand so
i don't know if that answers the
question
um
yeah if you have any other comments you
can comment them below and i'll answer
them but yeah that's why i don't just
like go to my parents for every little
thing
because one my parents would tell me to
go f off basically
and
um they're like this is a business go
make money
like they're not they're not idiots so
yeah i don't know does that answer your
question
let me know in the comments don't forget
to subscribe ring that notification bell
and oh last comment i don't even take
money for myself at this point like all
the money that you guys have donated i
just reinvest into the channel so
yeah
like i'm not even taking [ __ ] home at
this point so
don't forget to subscribe bye